اعلن البيت الابيض اعاده ادراج جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه وقال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن ان الحوثيين شنوا
هجمات غير مسبوقه ضد سفن في البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن وضد القوات المتمركزه في
المنطقه من جانبه قال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سوليفان قال ان هذا تصنيف
سيس خلال 30 يوما وذلك لاتاحه الوقت من
اجل تقليل اثار هذا القرار على الشعب
اليمني واضاف انه اذا اوقف الحوثيون
هجماتهم في البحر الاحمر فستس واشنطن رفع
هذا التصنيف واوضح سوليفان ان واشنطن تريد
ان يجبر هذا التصنيف ان يجبر الحوثيين على
الابتعاد عن
ايران قال المتحدث باسم انصار الله
الحوثيين محمد عبد السلام للجزيره قال ان
تصنيف الامريكي لن يثني الجماعه عن موقفها
الثابت الداعم للفلسطينيين واضاف انه لا
فاعلي على الارض لقرار واشنطن بشان تصنيف
انصار الله جماعه
ارهابيه انا اؤكد ان هذا التصنيف لن لن
يثني اليمن عن المواصله في موقفها المساند
لفلسطين وللمظلوم في قطاع غزه المحاصرين
ولا يمكن الا ان ان يزيد اليمنيين قوه
وصلابه وتمسكا بهذا الموقف المشروع
والمسؤول والمنسجم حتى مع القانون الدولي
نحن من حيث الفاعليه على الارض اؤكد انه
لا فاعليه لهذا القرار على الاطلاق لانها
جاءت جاء التصنيف متاخرا وقد سبقه كل ما
يستلزم التصنيف من اجراءات قد جاءتنا
مسبقا عبر سنوات سابقه لهذا نحن لا نعتقد
ان هذا جديد ولن يؤثر باعتبار انه نحن
اصلا في حاله التاثير وهذا شيء مؤسف ان
امريكا اظهرت على الاقل وجهها الحقيقي
تجاه اليمن اليوم بشكل
واضح معنا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
دكتور خليل اهلا بك بعد ساعات قليله من
الاعلان عن ادراج جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين في او على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه جاء الاعلان قبل قليل فقط عن
مصدر ملاحي للجزيره عن استهداف سفينه في
البحر الاحمر من قبل انصار الها الحوثيين
كيف يمكن قراءه وفهم هذين
التطور تحياتي لك وسيله والساده المشاهدين
هذا التطور في اطار حرب مفتوحه نشهد على
مدار الاسابيع الماضيه تصعيد واضح جدا من
قبل امريكا وبريطانيا فيما يتعلق باستهداف
والاعتداء على اليمن كما حدث الجمعه
الماضيه نحن اذاء حاله تصعيد واضحه تماما
ما جرى اليوم من خلال التصنيف دعيني فقط
اوضح للساده المشاهدين ان هنا هناك نوعين
من التصنيفات داخل امريكا لمنظمات
الارهابيه تصنيف داتا طبيعه خاصه ومحدده
وتصنيف ذات طبيعه عامه وشامله نحن اليوم
اذاء تصنيف يطلق عليه سبيشال يتد جلوبال
تورست انتيتي يعني التصنيف كيان عالمي
ارهابي ذ طبيعه خاصه محدده وهذا يختلف عن
ما يطلق عليه فورست اشن او منظمات اجنبيه
ارهابيه منظمات ارهابيه اجنبيه الفارق
فيما يلي اولا نحن اذا تصنيف اليوم تصنيف
لحد بعيد رتبط بالاساس بالامور والتعاملات
الماليه والاصول الماليه خاصه للافراد او
للكانات المصنفه ارهابيا وبالتالي هو فقط
يختص بهذا البعد متعلق بالتمويل ومتعلق
بالارصده ارصده البنوك ومتعلق خاصه
بالتعاملات مع بنوك ومؤسسات ماليه امريكيه
الامر الثاني المهم جدا انه نطاقه الى حد
بعيد لا يرتبط بسفر او ح حضر سفر الافراد
المرتبطين بهذا الكيان وبالتالي هو فقط
مرتبط بالمعاملات الماليه الامر الثالث
والاهم يتعلق بالجهات الداعمه والممول
لهذا الكيان بنتكلم على ما يطلق عليه
ماتريال سبورت والذي قد يشمل تمويل مالي
دعم عسكري دعم تكنولوجي دعم استخباراتي
ودعم عسكري وبالتالي اعتقد انه المقصود
هنا بالاساس هو ايران من هذا التصنيف
الامر الاخير هنا تصنيف لحد بعيد تصنيف قد
يكون مؤقت وليس دائم وهذا الامر جاء على
لسان جيك سوليفان عندما قال انه قد يتم
عاده النظر في الامر بعد 30 يوم من الان
وكذلك الامر على لسان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وبالتالي نحن زء تصاعد في هذا
الموضوع استمرار التخبط الامريكي في
التعاطي مع اززه الملاحه العالميه في
البحر الاحمر دكتور خليل جيك سوليفان قال
ان هذا الاعلان سيسري او سيبدا العمل به
بعد 30 يوم وبالتالي الى اي مدى يمكن
القول ان هذا التصنيف الجديد يدخل في خانه
الضغط وليس العقوبه على عكس ما جرى خلال
اداره
ترامب الى حد بعيد اولاب نوضح وسيله ان
تصنيف ترامب لم يستمر اكثر من عده اسبيع
بنتكلم على تصنيف جر على الاقل في اواخر
ايامه في اواخر عهده يعني بنتكلم على اخر
اسبوع من ولايته في يناير 2021 وتم الغاءه
بعدها بحوالي اربع اسابيع او اقل من ذلك
حتى في السا ع من فبراير 2021 كلم
وبالتالي نتكلم على فتره تتجاوز شهر على
اقصى تقدير فيما يتعلق بما حدث اليوم هو
بالفعل ياتي في اطار محاوله الضغط على
الحوثيين الردع بشكل او باخر محاوله وقف
هجماتهم او نشاطهم في البحر الاحمر
تخويفهم او راجعهم والاكثر اهميه من ذلك
فك الارتباط بينه وبين ايران وهذا الامر
جاء بشكل صريح على الاسان جاك سوليفان
عندما قال قد او نامل ان يؤدي هذا الامر
الى ابعاد الحوثيين عن ايران لكن انا في
ظني سيتي بالعكس هذا الامر لن يؤدي على
الاطلاق الى فك الارتباط بين طهران وبين
الحوثيين يؤدي على الاطلاق لتخفيض التصعيد
بالعكس قد نشى التصعيد اكثر من ذلك نحن
اذاء توقف الملاحه ب بشكل شبه كامل في
البحر الاحمر نحن اذاء هجمات وهجمات مضاده
من الطرفين نالي السؤال دكتور خليل الرد
اسم فقط الرد جاء بسرعه من اليمن انصار
الله الحوثيين قالوا لا فاعليه لهذا
التصنيف الامور ستستمر على حالها وبالتالي
ما الخيارات التي تملكها واشنطن امام هذا
التحدي من قبل انصار الله
الحوسين لا توجد خيارات وسيله سوى التفاوض
والحوار اي ازمه في الملاحه العالميه لا
تحل عن طريق القوه العسكريه عن طريق
البلطجه الامريكيه نحن زاء منطق امريكي
يكوم على الغطرسه وعلى القوه بالفعل يعالج
العرض وليس مرض قلنا اكثر من مره المشكله
الرئيسيه موجوده في قطاع غزه موجوده في
الدعم العسكري والدبلوماسي والسياسي
الامريكي المحدود لاسرائيل
موجود
شكرا ج علاج الازمه الحقيقيه في قطاع غزه
وبالتالي انه نحن اذاء جديد في هذه الازمه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر اعتذر منك الصوت كان
يتقطع دكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه حدثنا من
واشنطن اشكرك جزيل الشكر